if you're succeeding at something that
you don't enjoy imagine how great you'd
be at something you love and even if you
do go down that path and you fail even
if you fall flat on your face even if
you move back into your parents there is
going to be a little part of you that's
like well I gave it a go I know it's
again another like privilege thing to
say but I think there's something quite
cool in that people are more worried
about how they CV looks then they're
like they're like oh if I move now I've
only been in this job a year mate this
is about you enjoying your life not
trying to appease a stranger with a A4
piece of paper you know I went traveling
a few times I was younger and I remember
someone saying oh it doesn't make your
CV look good I would sit in that
interview and go I didn't want to work
anymore I went to travel I had the best
time but now I've realized I want to be
back working I was just straight with
them but imagine saying to someone like
I wanted to give everything I could to
something that didn't work out that's
actually more of a reason to be
impressed with someone than someone that
left a job every 2 years perfectly
looking for the next progression